[Music]
hey guys please welcome back to et live
this is our final Big Brother breakdown
of the season for Celebrity Big Brother
I am Bryce sander I'm Katie Krause what
a finale what a finale not at all what
anyone was expecting we sort of expected
it going back to the very beginning of
the episode for those who don't know
yes Oh spoiler alert if you haven't
watched yet not sure why you would tune
in for this if you haven't watched it
but we are gonna be spoiling the whole
season so if you don't want to know
anything about this season click on out
come back later we are going to
questions though send them yes we want
to talk about it and break it all down
yes so we're gonna look back at the best
moments from last night's finale and
have all these exclusive nuggets from
the BBU backyard where I was last night
with all the houseguests and Queen Julie
okay your take Marissa
one not at all what I was expecting I I
kind of called this final two from the
beginning at least they were a really
strong pair I thought yeah they're gonna
take each other to the end but I really
thought people would reward the game
play over she was nice to me this is the
second season in a row where that's
happened no bitter jury better jury do
you think that's them being able to go
back and watch all the episodes the jury
made an impact here's the thing I talked
I asked a lot of them either in our exit
interviews that we did week to week or
last night if they planned to slash did
they watch anything back most of them
didn't watch any of it back or if they
did they just watch little clips
highlights like james maslow relied on
his dad telling him what happened at his
fans okay brandy said she didn't have
enough time to really watch a lot of it
she saw some clips here and there I
think really the only person who watched
everything that she could was Shannon
because she's in the ultimate Big
Brother fan and player Brice asked all
of them oh like why they voted certain
way so we're gonna play all those clips
for you guys throughout this show let's
kick it off by watching the winning
moment because
always fun to see and she was shocked
Marissa was it shocked
congratulations Marissa
big brother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
of course her waving to her son enjoying
which I love that he was such a big fan
of the show and his mom won yes and he
was in the backyard with her last night
for her interviews it was also so cool
to watch everybody was happy for her
that she wants yeah that was what was
strange and different about Celebrity
Big Brother is they were all still kind
of friendly at the end like nobody while
there may have been bitter votes I think
they all saw it as a game or at least a
job okay which is you know normal dig
brother people see it as like this is
life-changing for them I think it was
like this is a job I'm doing so you felt
all good vibes in that yes in the
backyard as people are coming out yeah
screams were happening eyes they were
reconnecting seeing each other it was
really cute nobody was avoiding each
other nobody was trying to stay away we
became a family yes let's watch Marisa
reacting to her big win last night right
after in the backyard all right Marissa
can we celebrate for a second
can you believe my wine have you been
older process that you know I wasn't
supposed to win I'm completely shocked
and I have no idea yeah I don't how
don't know how to react it's totally
surreal well I think it was a shock it
was a shock for Julie for sure
well happy without Ross is gonna take it
home what do you think it was that
sealed the deal for you um I think
because what's weird was even Julie was
like I can't believe you took Ross I was
such a bad choice my son when my husband
were both like why did you do that
here's the deal I wouldn't have been
where I was if I didn't take if I hadn't
been playing with Ross Ross saved me
time after time my alliance with Ross
was the only real like true like we had
each other's back the whole time and you
have to trust somebody in the house
right
so I trusted him and he trusted me so
not taking him to me wasn't part of my
spirit I was yes I'm a big brother fan
and I know in the big brother land that
was the worst move but in my heart and
in my soul and being a mother and
wanting to show like no if you have a
good friend regardless of what the
outcome is you take your friend you
could see her husband and her son in the
background there taking pictures
you know what just for her saying that I
feel like she deserved to win like
that's a good way and a positive outlook
and she was loyal to Ross and she was
somebody that she knew the game yeah she
didn't maybe didn't play as hard but
when you think about it she did win the
competitions that matter
right okay question do you think if Ross
would have won that final HOH that he
would have taken more risks at a final
two I asked him about this he played it
coy he said Marissa was his ride-or-die
but it would have been hard to not take
mark he said and he said it would have
been easier for me to win against mark
but he wouldn't give me a clear answer
so I really think it would have come
down to that gametime decision any
probably because he was such a player
all season would have taken mark all
right you guys have a lot of thoughts
feelings emotions about this Shelly said
Marissa did not deserve to win biggest
floater ever while katie was happy for
her mm-hmm Debbie says Ross played the
best game actually a lot of you guys are
saying that Ross should have won
I am very shocked I do feel like he had
the strongest social game I felt like he
was playing both sides of the house
which as we've seen in some seasons
really does end up doing well for these
bro I mean I think of Andy yeah doing
that there's a that's kind of how people
used to win the game and then the last
few seasons that's changed Julie had
some thoughts on this so let's see what
Queen Chen bought had to say I was
shocked I mean I thought oh I have this
figured out
first I thought she's not gonna pick him
because you know she didn't expect to
win HOH and I thought oh she's gonna
tell him on the side listen I've got to
win this for my son my husband my family
personal reasons and then when she did
pick him I thought oh wow he just made a
huge mistake you just lost the game like
it was in your hands and then when the
vote count was 6 to 3 I thought wow I
did not expect that people are holding
grudges people are voting emotionally
but this is big brother and I've seen
that happen before this is big brother
I love how invested julia's she's a fan
of the show yes and that makes me happy
watching it and knowing that she's been
the host for so many years she actually
cares she actually watches and she's
just as invested as we are as the
viewers are and I'm gonna get that
interview up for you guys later today on
ET online so you can see all of Queen
Jen BOTS thoughts including what she
knows about season 20 coming next summer
yeah but as you note it was a six
vote in Russia's favour and brandy was
the only woman who voted for Ross and
she explains to you why she yeah so
here's that I you know I love Ross your
friends outside the house and I think
that people were taking it a little too
personally
it is a game he played the best game
Marissa you know kind of rode his
coattails she let him do all the dirty
work and then spoofed in and knew he was
gonna be the villain and it's like you
can sit with me and by so you know I
just I thought that he played the best
game
it's a shady game but that is the game
and if anybody knows a shady game its
Brandi Glanville hundred percent I do
agree with what she said though I mean
Ross did play the better games won more
competitions I think he was going back
and forth through the house so much more
than Marissa was as he said on that
stage last night he was like I'm sorry
for the lies but that's the game and he
kept saying that he was pivoting the
game a lot which is true but I thought
that all the women were gonna vote for
Marissa just because they had made that
pact early on do you think that that
went into some of the oh for sure I
think that I think people wanted I think
the girls as much as they fought and
fell apart so soon they were they
somewhere deep inside were like I sew on
a girl to win this game it didn't just
worked out that way
I still have hope for a girl's Alliance
making it to the end in the future so I
think it could have happened if this was
a full-length season a big yeah when
they had more time though what was
interesting was last night they were
saying how bored they were in the house
it felt so fast for me for a viewers
yeah but they would go because of the
way it was set up they would have a
weekend where things moved really fast
and then they have a whole week where
nothing happened so Shannon said I would
have loved to seen more luxury comps or
things where the house was put it
against like there were sides in the
house right just for them to have
something interesting to do I said her
yeah surprised that we didn't see an
Outback Steakhouse dinner yeah I would
have loved at least two more weeks
tacked on to this yes because I feel
like a lot of choices were made so
quickly without letting it marinate it's
because they all thought there was gonna
be more double evictions at least there
would have to be because of how fast
things work out but Julie did say should
they do another season which I totally
think they will was such a success that
she doesn't think
it'll be 5 in the finale ever again
because they don't want anybody going in
with a thought as to what this show will
be yeah that's fair I think that that is
a good choice and a good switch that
they should make let's talk about Metta
World Peace and his vote because did he
really just pick a random key so I had
to ask him in the backyard and if he
answered in the most meta way possible
it's a little hard to follow but here's
what he had to say about picking a
person at random I need glasses and a
some good prescription so even when I
look into my eyes open I can see I said
I might as well closer and I picked and
it was hard because Ross played a great
game I'm a recipe in a really good
social game being a mother like figuring
Russ being a hell of a player and he
didn't think he can win he did and I'm
happy for him I really didn't care one
so I just whatever key came out that was
a heat I was going wow so he really did
just he picked Ross at random and I
think he thinks Ross won yeah I think
he's still very confused he's still very
confused I loved watching Joey try and
get his attention three times like you
understand what you're doing here but
yeah I do love meta though everybody
loves medic that was everybody's friend
for life out of this game wasn't meta I
saw that um Jeanie buss of course who
owns the Lakers was supporting him like
all throughout the season she was there
I think last night or she posted a
picture was she had a reason he signed
up for this she's like she's a huge fan
and he said he would love to see Kobe
play the game me too I would love that
or Derek Fisher yeah I said you got to
put in a call yeah I'll leave that to
CBS yeah somebody else with an
interesting vote last night was James or
at least he had a statement before his
vote that was interesting he said the
speeches changed his mind at the last
minute and his vote was for Marissa I
wonder what happened did you ask him yes
well I don't know that it was definitive
before for Ross to be honest but I do
respect that he played the game his way
you got to separate the game from
reality and you're allowed to backstab
you're allowed to do all those things
you're not as a little surprised that
some of it was to me when he took credit
for winning an HOH that I gave to him in
his speech that was like you know you
should have phrased it better he
actually came off a little bit too
confidence funny enough something I got
a lot of crap for about the game and to
see Marissa is such an underdog win this
game to get that far with no blood on
her hands doing it gracefully and with
tact something I tried to do between
those things I was like you know what
I'd really like to see her way so Wow
yes because he took credit for the bull
arena
HOH which actually Shannon Orchestra yes
so you can see now we have a little more
Intel as to how things played out yeah
Ross what do you guys think of that do
you think that Ross took credit for too
much Winnie
well Angelica said he should have owned
up to the game more he was very
secretive about all the big roaring he
was doing he should have just been like
I pivoted I pivoted he should have said
you know I told this person this and
then I told this person this it was like
I pivoted but then he said my strategy
never changed yeah but it was kind of
all over the place it did change Ross
but it did work out for him good yes he
won America's favorite player which it
came down to Shannon James and Ross I'd
love to know the order in which the
other and the I would I want to know the
numbers I'll be honest I gave all my
votes
I gave 18 of them to Shannon and 2 for
James I think a lot of people voted for
Shannon I'm surprised that she did not
win that but I thought meta would be up
there right over Ross that was what was
interesting well Shannon's reaction to
this you just gotta watch it this was
her in the backyard after were you
surprised to see Ross take home
America's favorite player that's how
America voted so I mean he he was afraid
he was the villain and he must be like
so that's how it is that's how it is
yeah she was she seems not to she was
not too happy what do you think it was
like what sealed the deal for us
for winning America's failure yes I
honestly think I mean this is there are
celebrities they have fan bases I think
he has a lot of connections in the
celebrity world I think people were
campaigning for him and I think it was
also maybe more people were watching
voting off of the TV show and not live
feeds like maybe feeders weren't voting
okay cuz I'm a live feed you could
really see a lot of the manipulation
that was go
a lot of the lies on the show his diary
room interviews were so fun to watch so
maybe that's what helped he was kind of
the narrator of the season yeah
but Shannon was still she said she
didn't want to see her ass and Marissa
up there she talked about seeing them
because she got a glimpse on the monitor
before they revealed it and she was just
her face sink well she was here and she
was still not so happy with him I hope
they can mend the friendships well I
think they're all I think she was still
so much in game mode I think when she
steps out of game mode everybody's gonna
be friends she still said she still
loves this game she'll still watch the
show she still wants to do that thing
she pitched us where she kind of is the
coach for the season and sets the times
yep so that I hope that happens that'll
be a great season I agree I would watch
it I'm gonna watch it no matter what but
I would love to see her on another
season and get some justice justice for
Shannon Elizabeth yes because I think
she really is one of the best people to
ever play this game great
responsibilities all right so on the
topic of Ross I had to ask him about
when he put on his investigative
journalism cap oh I'm a Rossa and got
some stuff out of Omarosa which he
didn't even know if that had aired so
this was his reaction to learning that
we all got to see what he asked Omarosa
but your investigative journalism cap on
and got stuff out of Omarosa see I don't
even know if that air did that air I
deserved some sort of Pulitzer Prize or
something right I got the dirt did that
that aired people saw it it was every
single episode there was a nugget from
Omarosa what was your reaction to
hearing all that stuff I was just
thinking this is gonna be huge outside
the house you know what I mean I felt
like you guys sent me there to get to
get it out of her and so I was on a
mission
I'm so happy people saw that because I'm
getting stuff in the backyard going this
is gold
they better be putting this on the show
when she told you that we should be
worried and scared around the world it
was like oh so that was news yeah you're
welcome
do you think I'll get like some sort of
investigative journalism award he should
really show great questions he got
Omarosa to open up about what happened
in the white house yes I think that from
that he deserves what he wants I think
that factored into people's votes for
America Sarah because he really did they
made that so much of what was
in the episodes he put in work he put in
the work he got it out of her he was
really the only one actively asking her
questions day after day week after week
yeah no I was not allowed to ask Omarosa
questions about the white house in the
backyard
we were told everything about the White
House President Trump her time there
anything she said in the house anything
about her upcoming book all off-limits
but I tried my best to get because
you're great so here's what she said
about stepping into the real world and
getting the feedback on everything she
said absolutely no contact whatsoever
with the outside world and and it was
that was challenging for me but also at
a time when I need it to be cut off from
the outside world
I loved not having to know what was
going on in the news or Twitter or
anything like that so it was a blessing
are you ready to now step back into that
world and see what the response to you
was and the things you said no in fact
I'm going back into the Big Brother
house for another month announcement
you've heard it here I'm not leaving I'm
not ready to leave yet no I'm kidding I
will see what tomorrow holds but for now
I'm just gonna hold on to my husband and
just soak up all the loving it's
interesting because Omarosa is so smart
she's so she's brilliant she knows what
she was doing in my opinion everything
every little breadcrumb that she dropped
I think she knew she was doing yeah and
I don't think it was game strategy I
think it was life strategy like she knew
this was kind of her moment to continue
her 15 minutes on this train and to blow
it up and get people keep the interest
going I mean she has a book coming out
fairly soon so it makes sense but
regardless I was still happy to hear all
the different information that she was
giving - oh definitely I mean she said
her piece in the finale she's gonna be
on the talk today where I'm sure she'll
say a lot more it'll be interesting to
watch because that was what was
fascinating about everybody saying who
surprising the most was Omarosa they all
had this preconceived notion of who she
was and I think she was the player that
they could all separate between when she
was playing the game and just who she
was as a person yes they all kind of
said she was villain when it came to
gameplay but a friend for life right was
I mean even look like her and Shannon
made up last night I saw them hugging
yes did you see anything between them
did they look friendly I didn't watch
anything with them but literally Omarosa
was the last person to walk into the
back yard she kept us waiting for the
longest time I thought I don't think
she's coming back here she stepped in
and immediately everybody screamed ran
over to hug her she was taking pictures
with everybody so they all really bonded
they all really liked her as a person
she said she this is what she did tell
me about Shannon she and her husband are
planning a couple's getaway to South
Africa to visit Shannon and her
boyfriend so almost I said for the next
month or so she's just gonna plan some
trips and go see her new Big Brother fan
friends who live all over the country I
think she's gonna go to Atlanta and see
Kisha I love that and you know what I'll
be honest I actually came to love
Omarosa I was rooting for her I loved
her and it shocked me mice told her I
said I think you are going to be
surprised at how surprised the reaction
was to you and she said she was shocked
yeah that people respond we're
responding in a positive way uh and
she's I think she's gonna take a moment
before she watches anything her looks at
anything she said she really enjoyed
being away from everything like she said
and she's gonna try to extend that as
long as she can yeah I said she'll let
us know what she thinks of the response
to her I can't wait for that um Donna
says un in Haiti and Omarosa
now I admire her what a great speech at
the end love to her and her family I
think she changed a lot of people's
perceptions yeah well I asked her if it
was how this was different from all her
reality TV experiences and she said it
was the first time where she was cut off
from the world so she wasn't being
influenced by anything outside she just
was free to be herself I think we saw
that those are the moments that I
appreciated the most those candid
moments those moments where she was just
talking one-on-one with certain people I
do question some of her gameplay yeah as
a person she's doing - like in a reality
TV villain and a player yeah Angelica
says she was surprised that she could
actually enjoy watching omorosa
considering that I see her as a villain
and Doug says she was a great villain
amazing
see I don't think she wasn't I think
they had trouble defining the villain
because like I said this to James when I
interviewed him on Friday after his
eviction
I said you kind of got the villain edit
those first couple episodes which he was
surprised to hear and then I think it
shifted toward Omarosa when they
realized James was no longer the biggest
target in the house and was actually
maybe going to be there longer than a
week and then I went to Ross I would say
towards those final days but not you you
saw all the manipulation I think it
helped Ross that Omarosa was in there
until the final episode because if she
were out and there were two episodes or
so to Phil then I think we could have
seen a twist who I think was the nicest
person in that house mark McGrath he did
not say a single bad word about anyone
know and I don't he made any final final
deals with anybody he's so honest he was
playing it for fun
Anna says on live feeds is where you
actually saw the real Almirola say yes
yeah there were some moments some heated
discussions especially with Shannon
before she left they did she wind up
showing on that Saturday episode that
was the clip show showed the race moment
that Shannon told us about when she was
here for our recap last week they
actually played that out in full yeah um
Sarah says you know someone is real when
they make you feel the way al Moroso
does so true Sarah interesting all right
we don't know if we're getting another
season of BB celeb Julie said it'll
matter they have to have the casting
right they had to figure out the timing
again because the only reason they did
this was counter-programming for the
Olympics right but it went up being huge
ratings hydrogen who would you like to
see play this game oh my gosh um Lisa
Vanderpump hmm just is she's so smart
I'm gonna go with who Shannon said she
wants play this game and I've asked him
about this before Lance Bass
because he loves big loves big brother I
think he would be an awesome player and
I mean neat homelands are friends they
are friends which would be interesting
yeah though this is when I enter I
interviewed them both at Lisa Vanderpump
Dog Foundation gala last fall when this
casting when this was announced this was
happening Lance said it wasn't enough
money for him so maybe some things have
changed okay and he said but he did
wanting he's his response was we should
get Lisa in the house when they said
Lisa will never share a bathroom
that makes sense I'd also like to see
Aaron Carter that would be interesting
he was actually offered it for this
season but it didn't work out with the
timing of his new music but I think he's
such a polarizing figure that he would
be interesting to watch there
Marisa told me she wants to see the
actors who played Xena got in the house
Lucy Lawless yeah interesting which I
was like okay yeah and then you know
other people were dreaming really big
Brandi wants to see Oprah play
I mean who wouldn't and Julie China's
sticking by she wants scaramouche II to
come in and say and she thinks that
Omarosa experience might convince him
okay to come play which may be I think
it's 15 minutes may be over by the time
we get there we're happy to help cast
and though I'm also gonna put ups at
some point they all told me what they
want to see changed in the house but I'm
not gonna reveal it yet I want you to go
to ET online there's some good stuff in
there I'm just gonna tease it that way
yes I do hope moving forward to this
summer that we get an all-star season
it's big season its season 20 who would
you like to see come back if that's the
case I mean there's so many people I'd
love to see see play again and some of
them are people who have played again
I'm a big fan of the strong women yes I
want to now play again I want to see
Brittany play again I want to see Rachel
play again me too
from dr. well yes if you had to pick
somebody from last season to play again
ooh Paul Paul a three feet maybe you
could get that vital 232 blow so many
times and he's so fun to watch his diary
rooms are so funny and candid and you
really see how he's working the game I
think he chokes when it comes to
answering questions from the journey and
so I want to see him you know maybe
people have learned by a third so yeah
we have to stay it will have to stay
tuned for that I will have julie chen's
interview up later today where you can
see her thoughts on season 20 in which
she kind of thinks is gonna happen well
wrap this up here you guys can continue
the conversation with us over on Twitter
we wanna hear a lot of talk oh thanks
baby I'm at Bryce sander I'm Katie
underscore Krause and don't forget to
subscribe to ET on YouTube like us on
Facebook so you don't miss when we do
fun recaps like this yes absolutely
thank you guys for watching with us and
we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you